president joe biden's presidency is in a
tailspin and the bad news keeps piling
up for the commander-in-chief the
spending agenda stalled and democrats
are divided over how to spend these
trillions biden's poll numbers are
cradling to an all-time low inflation
ramping up with prices surging and now
add the jobs disaster to the list only
194 000 were added in september far
below the estimates anticipating a half
a million jobs would be added it's the
worst jobs report of his presidency so
far but don't worry
biden says he's making real progress
today's report has the unemployment rate
down to 4.8 percent
a significant improvement
from when i took office the monthly
totals bounce around but if you take a
look at the trend it's solid things in
washington as you all know are awfully
noisy
turn on the news and every conversation
is a confrontation
every disagreement is a crisis but when
you take a step back and look at what's
happening we're actually making real
progress maybe it doesn't seem fast
enough i'd like to see it faster we're
making consistent steady progress though
and just yesterday biden was bragging
about the unvaxxed being fired
more lives are being saved let's be
clear when you see headlines and reports
of mass firings and hundreds of people
losing their jobs
look at the bigger story
so he's saying it's good that unvaxed
americans were laid off kennedy the
recovery is stalling that's clear this
was a v and then it started to fade and
there's millions and millions of jobs
still open about 11 million and
americans really aren't trying to fill
them well the white house can't make
sense of it and i think one of the
biggest things they have going against
them is they're being completely
disingenuous with the messaging and it's
actually okay to let people know that
sometimes things aren't going great and
unfortunately for this administration a
lot of things are going wrong and that's
showing up in the polls you know the
quinnipiac poll that we showed every
single measure of the president is under
water the economy coronavirus
immigration tax afghanistan taxes
inflation it's all bad for him and you
know things like inflation sandra will
tell you that's not getting better any
time soon and even the fed which was
doing the same thing the white house
does which is tried to paint this
short-term rosy picture now they have to
admit that it's a long-term problem and
i i just i get really sick of sitting
through briefings from the president and
from gen soccer and the communications
team where they essentially are lying to
people yeah what about what you just
said richard if you have a problem in
this recovery why doesn't the president
just say listen we've slowed it down
here's what i'm going to do to address
it just be patient we got this instead
he just spins and lies and that's why
people don't trust them well listen i
tend to agree with um with kennedy here
i think that the white house could have
come out today and said listen this is
not the best jobs report and this speaks
to why we need the buildback better plan
and i think he could have made a pivot
to talk about how this one of the one
things we one thing we saw in this job
to support were a lot of the losses of
jobs were to women right a lot of women
lost jobs in this report which speaks to
the fact that you know a lot of women
aren't going back to work because they
have child care issues a lot of women
aren't going back to work because of
wage issues all things that biden has
talked about over and over again
addressing in the buildback better plan
so this has been a great opportunity for
him to say hey it's not going well but
when we pass this plan women will be
able to have some help when it comes to
paying for childcare so they can go back
to work they could be back in their
offices and don't have to worry about
how they're going to pay the mortgage
that now is early childhood education
for many families so i would hope to see
this president come out and usu really
talk about what his agenda is and how
his agenda can move the whole country
forward not just democrats not just
republicans with the entire country it's
weird because greg was saying in the
green room highway he was happy that
women were not coming back and they
deserve to stay home yes i you know what
i wish you'd kept that private
but now everybody knows what a sexist
pig i am
every time i hear build back
better i just want to say build back
brandon
if joe's poll numbers are really in the
toilet maybe activists might form a line
outside to talk to them oh yeah
i like it it's friday and i don't care
all right could you imagine if joe faced
the same scrutiny as trump did or if
trump faced the same scrutiny as joe
biden did so if trump would either be
the greatest president that ever lived
if he had the joe treatment and dro
would be the worst president that ever
lived if he got the trump treatment i
find that highly interesting i think
this guy has been in politics for over a
half a century and he sucks so this
isn't this isn't really a comment on
biden
it tells you that politics the longer
you're in it the experience doesn't
improve your competence in fact it might
be the reverse
yeah and they're forever yeah it might
be this could be a condition where the
more you're in something the worse you
become which is when you compare trump
who was never in politics you did more
in in a year than biden did in a
lifetime no political experience right
you love him or hate him emotionally oh
he hurts me so much he did a lot have
you have we talked about north korea in
a while anyway the fact is biden's been
around forever he's terrible awful but
you look at a lot of people it's not
just him it's kerry as well it is fauci
it is pelosi the longer people are in
this machine the worse it is and um
i don't know what the answer to it is
except maybe we stop electing these p
these lifers
force them out and he blames everything
on covet sandra that was a little
disconcerting that the the cove
excuse was still there when explaining
the miss on the jobs report i feel like
i want to just do a bit of a service to
our viewers and say that i was just
chatting with larry kudlow and and
and probably he would take every reason
to criticize this jobs report he feels
like the media actually really got this
wrong and that there was actually some
really notable gains in the jobs report
that we should highlight the big drop
that held back that headline job growth
number was the local government
education jobs fell 144 000 there was
otherwise gains people are going back
into leisure and hospitality
i think you saw a gain in entertainment
the recreation sector there were
actually some notable gains and average
hourly earnings did go up so i don't
want to take away from those gains
are those gains when you're just
replacing going back to what was there
yeah
the point is the loss in the government
education is more seen as seasonal
anyway that being said to your point
about messaging when i saw joe biden
speaking at that podium today obviously
there wasn't a real opportunity to take
a victory lap but the messaging and the
acknowledgement of the reality of the
situation when it comes to inflation
he's pulling horribly when it comes to
inflation people don't want to be
spending more for absolutely everything
he's got a major supply supply chain
crisis going on right now to the point
where we're going to our local
pharmacies and grocery stores and they
don't have our basic needs i mean this
is a huge problem that has to be
acknowledged by this administration you
are not seeing that happen but the other
thing was he used that speech today
after the jobs report to talk a lot
about and to pitch his infrastructure
package as a way to get people back to
work well fine then separate the two
massive bills take a straight up or down
vote on the standalone infrastructure
bill if that's the key to getting people
back to work why doesn't he ask congress
to do but he can't do that because
they're now on a two-track if the
moderates vote for the
1.5 infrastructure they're probably not
going to go for the 3.5 trill but at
least the president gets a win you know
to sanders point at least he gets when
they need it desperately given these
poll numbers it's just you know horrible
politics all the way up it would be a
huge win bipartisan we need a win
america needs a win forget about biden